the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
ok so I'm gonna talk about gradient sent
today to get that to that central
algorithm of neural nets deep learning
machine learning and optimization in
general so I'm trying to minimize a
function and that's the way you do it if
there are many many variables too many
to take second derivatives then we
settle for first derivatives of the
function ok so I introduced and you've
already met the idea of gradient but let
me just be sure to make some comments
about the gradient and the Hessian and
the role of convexity before we see the
big a crucial example so I've kind of
prepared over here for this crucial
example the function is a pure quadratic
- two unknowns X and y pure quadratic so
every pure quadratic I can write in
terms of a symmetric matrix s and in
this case X 1 squared plus BX 2 squared
the symmetric the matrix is just 2x2 its
diagonal it's got I can values 1 and B
sitting on the diagonal I'm thinking of
B as being the smaller one so the
condition number which we'll see is all
important in question of the speed of
convergence is the ratio of the largest
to the smallest
in this case the largest is one the
smallest is B so that's one over B and
when that's a when one over B is a big
number when B is a very small number
then that's when we're in trouble there
condition number of a matrix submit when
the matrix is symmetric that condition
number is lambda max over lambda min if
I had a unsymmetric matrix I would
probably use Sigma max over Sigma min of
course but here matrices are symmetric
okay we're going to see something neat
is that we can actually take the steps
of steepest descent write down what each
step gives us and see how quickly they
converge to the answer and what is the
answer so Y minima I haven't put in any
linear term here so I'm I just have a
bull sitting on the origin so of course
the minimum point is x equals 0 y equals
0 so the minimum point X star is 0 0 of
course
so the question it will be how quickly
do we get to that one and you'll say
pretty small example not typical but the
terrific thing is that we see everything
for this example we can see the actual
steps of steepest descent we can see how
quickly they converge to the x star the
answer the place where they're seen as a
minimum and we can begin to think what
to do if it's too slow okay so I'll come
back I'll come to that example after
some general thoughts about gradients
Hessians so what does the gradient tell
us so let me just take an example of the
gradient
now let me take a linear function f of
XY equals say 2x plus 5y I just think we
ought to get totally familiar with these
we're doing something you know we're
jumping into an important topic when I
ask you what's the gradient that's a
freshman question but let's just
remember we know how to interpret the
gradient how to compute it what it means
what it how to see it geometrically so
what's the gradient of that function
it's a function of two variables so the
gradient is a vector with two components
and they are the derivative with respect
to X which is 2 and the derivative is
vector Y which is 5 so that in this case
the gradient is constant and the Hessian
which I often call H after Hessian or
del squared F would tell us we're taking
second derivatives that will be the
second derivatives obviously zero in
this case so what what what shape is H
here it's 2 by 2 right everybody
recognizes 2 by 2 this H would have I
take the second derivative of that sorry
the first derivative of that with
respect to X obviously zero the first
derivative the respect to Y the first
derivative of that with respect to X Y
ok zero ok so let me draw the surface so
X Y and the surface if i graph f in this
direction then obviously I have a plane
and I'm at a typical point on the plane
let's say yeah yeah so I'm at a point X
Y I should say I'm at a point X Y and
let me put the plane through it ok so
how do I interpret the
at that particular point XY what does 2x
plus 5y tell me or what does rather what
does gratis
tell me about movement from that point
XY of course the gradient constant so it
really didn't matter what point I'm
moving from but taking a point here so
what's the deal
if I move what's the fastest way to go
up the surface if I took the plane that
went through that point XY what's the
fastest way to climb the plane what's
the what direction goes up fastest their
gradient direction right the gradient
direction is the way up how am I going
to put that in this picture I guess I'm
thinking of this plane as so what plane
you could it well ask what plane of I'd
drawn suppose I've drawn the plane 2x
plus 5y equal equal zero so I'll make
okay and I've taken a typical point on
that plane okay now if I want to
increase that function I go
perpendicular to the plane right if I
want to stay level with the function I
want it to stay at zero I stay in the
plane so there are two key directions
everybody knows this I'm just repeating
this is the direction of the gradient of
f out of the plane steepest upwards this
is the downwards direction minus
gradient of F perpendicular plane
downwards and this is the that line is
in the plane that's part of a level set
2x plus 5y equals zero would be a level
set okay that's my pretty amateur
picture just all I want to remember is
these words level
and steepest up or down down was a minus
sign that we see in in steepest descent
so we're in steepest ascent okay and and
what's the Hessian telling me about the
surface what if I take the matrix of
second derivatives oh yeah so I have
this surface so I have a surface F equal
constant that's the sort of level
surface so if I stay in that surface the
gradient of F is 0 gradient of F is 0
and in in in in on on the sir on is a
better word on the surface the gradient
of F points perpendicular but what does
the what what does what about the Heston
the second derivative what is that
telling me about
that surface in particular when the
Hessian is zero or other surfaces what
does the Hessian tell me about it says
I'm thinking of the Hessian at a
particular point so I get I'm getting
zero for the Hessian because the surface
is flat if the surface was convex
upwards from if it was a convex graph of
F the Hessian would be so what so I just
want to make that connection now what's
the connection between the Hessian and
convexity of the father the Hessian of
the function and convexity of the
function what so the point is that's the
yeah that convexity the the Hessian
tells me whether or not the surface is
convex and what is the test positive
definiteness or semi definite I'm just
looking for an excuse to write down
convexity and strong restrict do I say
stricter strong convexity I forgotten
strict I think strictly convex
okay so convexity the Hessian is
positive semi-definite or which includes
which I better say that right here
includes positive definite
and if I'm only if I'm looking for a
strict convexity then I must require
positive definite
H is positive definite semi definite
won't do so so semi definite for convex
so that in fact the the linear function
is convex but not strictly convex
strictly means it really bends upwards
the Hessian is positive definite that
curvatures are positive so so that this
this would include linear functions and
that would not include linear function
they're not strictly convex okay good
good good some examples okay the number
one example of course is the one we're
talking about over here
so examples f of X equal one half x
transpose X and of course I could have
linear terms minus a a transpose X a
linear term and I could have our concept
okay so so this function is strictly
convex when this is positive definite
because H s H is now F for this for that
function for that function H usually H
the Hessian is varying from point to
point the nice thing about the pure
quadratic is it's constant it's the same
s at all points okay let me just ask you
so that's a convex function and what's
its minimum what's the gradient first of
all what's the grainy in the bet
I'm asking really for differentiating
thinking Victini and Vector doing all n
derivatives that at once here I'm asking
for the whole vector of first
derivatives and because here I'm giving
you the whole function in with X for a
vector X of course we could take n to be
1 and then we would see that if n was 1
this would just be X X squares x squared
1/2 1/2 s x squared and the derivative
of 1/2 ik SX squared let me just put
that over here so we're sure to get it
right half of s x squared this is in the
n equal one case and the derivative is
obviously sx and that's what it is here
sx it really just you know it's
obviously simple but if you haven't
thought about that line it's asking for
all the part all the first derivatives
of that of that quadratic function oh
it's not what if I what if I what do I
have to include now here I didn't that's
not right as it stands for the function
that's written above it what's the right
gradient - a thanks because the linear
function it's partial derivatives that
are obviously just the components of a
ok and the Hessian H is s the
derivatives of that guy ok good good
good good and minimum value we might as
well oh yeah what's the right words for
a minimum value the no I'm sorry the
right word has minimum value like f men
so I want to compute FMN well first I
have to figure out where where is that
minimum reached and what's the answer to
that so that's just we're putting
everything on the board for this simple
case the minimum of f of f of f of X
remember it's X's we're in n dimensions
is at X equal what well the minimum is
where the gradient is zero so what's the
minimizing X s inverse a thanks
and what's the sorry that's not right
it's here that I meant to write it I
didn't really my whole point for this
little moment is to be sure that we keep
straight what I mean by the place where
the minimum is reached and the minimum
value those are two different things
okay so the minimum is reached at s
inverse a because that's obviously where
the gradient is zero it's a solution to
s X equal a and what I was going to ask
you is what's the right word well sort
of words scratch-made upward for the for
this point X star where the minimum is
reached so it's not the minimum value
it's the point where it's reached and
that's called the notation for that
point is argh men Thanks argh
mins of my function and that means the
place that's the point where F equals F
min
I haven't said yet what the minimum
value is this tells us the point and
that's usually what we're interested in
where to tell the truth not that
interested in a typical example that
what the minimum value is as much as
where is it where do we reach that thing
and of course so this is x-men this is
then are men of my function if that's
the point and it happens to be in this
case the minimum value is actually zero
so it goes because it because there's no
because there's no linear no linear term
a a transpose a okay III guess I feel
why am I talking about
armed men when you've all seen it III
guess I think that somebody could just
be reading this stuff for example
learning about neural nets and run into
this expression argument and think
what's that so it's it's maybe a right
time to say what it is it's the point
where the minimum is reached and that's
it's the why that why those words by the
way
well argh isn't much of a word that
sounds like you're getting strangled but
it's sort of short
I assume it's short nobody ever told me
this I assume it's short for argument
the word argument is a kind of long word
for the value of x if I have a function
f of X F I call a function and X is the
argument of the function you might often
more often see the word variable but but
argument and I'm assuming that's what
that refers to is the argument that
minimizes the function okay good and and
and
here it is s inverse a now but just by
the way what is F men do you know the
minimum of a quadratic I mean this is
the fundamental minimization question to
minimize a quadratic electrical
engineering the quadratic regulator
problem is the simplest problem there
there could be constraints and we'll see
it with constraints included but right
now no constraints at all we're just
looking at the function f of X and we
let me remove the B because that's just
shifts a function by B if I erase that
that's just to say it didn't matter it's
it's really that function so that
function actually goes through zero
right as it is when X is zero we
obviously get zero but it's still on its
way down so to speak it's on its way
down to this point s inverse a that's
where it bottoms out and when it bottoms
out what do you get for F one thing I
know it's going to be negative because
it passed through zero and it was on its
way below zero so let's just figure out
what that F min is so I have a half yeah
I'm just gonna plug in s inverse a the
bottom point into the function and see
what's the what's where the surface
bottoms out and and what at what at what
level it bottoms out so I have a half so
that's s inverse a is a transpose s
inverse s is symmetric so I'll just
write just inverse transpose s s inverse
a from the quadratic term minus a
transpose and X is s inverse a have
you've done this calculation if you it
just doesn't hurt to repeat it okay so
I've logged in s inverse a
there there and there okay what have I
got
well s inverse cancels s so I have a
half of a transpose s inverse a minus 1
of a transpose inverse a so I get
finally negative 1/2 half of it - 1 of
it of a transpose s inverse a sorry
that's not brilliant use of the
blackboard to squeeze that in there but
that's that's easily repeatable ok good
so that's what a quadratic bowl a
perfect quadratic problem minimizes to
where that's its lowest level ok I
wanted to mention one other function
because I'm going to speak mostly about
quadratic but obviously the whole point
is that it's the convexity that's really
making things work so so here I let me
just put here a remarkable convex
function and the notes tell what is that
what's the gradient of this function
they don't actually go as far as the
Hessian proving this as a convict
proving that this function I'm going to
write down is a convex is convex it
takes a little thinking but it's a it's
a fantastic function you would never
sort of imagine it if you didn't didn't
see it sometimes so I'm it's going to be
a function of a matrix a function of
those are N squared variables X IJ
so it's a function of many variables and
here's this function it's you take the
determinant of the matrix that's clearly
a function of all the N squared
variables then you take the log of the
determinant and put in a minus sign
because we want convex that that turns
out to be a convex function and even to
just check that for two by two
well for two by two you have four
variables because it's a two by two
matrix we could maybe check it for a
symmetric matrix I move down to three
variables but it's I'd be glad anybody
who's ambitious too to see why that log
determinant is is a remarkable function
and let me see I think I I think it is
so the gradient of that sink is also
amazing the gradient of that function I
mean I've got a peak so I don't write a
right to wrong fact here yep so the
partial derivatives of that function are
the entries of these are the entries of
of a inverse
that's the of X inverse
yeah that that's like wow where did that
come from okay
it might be - the entries of course yeah
yeah so we've got N squared function so
think of the well what is a typical
entry in in X inverse what is the
typical X inverse IJ just to remember
that bit of pretty old-fashioned linear
algebra the entries of the inverse
matrix
I'm sure - divided by what the
determinate that's the one thing we know
and that's the reason we take the log
because when you take derivatives of a
log you that will put determine of X in
the denominator and then the numerator
will be the derivatives of the
determinant of X Oh
can we get any idea what there are the
derivatives of the determinants oh my
god okay
so you with me so far this is gonna be
derivatives of determinants respect of
all these variables divided by the
determinant because that's what the log
achieved right so when I take the
derivative of the log of something the
chain rule says take the derivative of
that since of that something divided by
determinant vector divided by the
function determinant of X okay so what
what's the derivative of the determinant
of a matrix with respect to its one one
entry yes sure this is this is crazy but
it's crazy to be doing this but it's
healthy okay so
okay so I have a matrix X Delta X X 1 1
X 1 n so 2 xn 1 xn n ok and what am I
looking for I'm looking for that for the
derivatives of that do I want the
derivatives of the determinants yes so
what's the derivative of X of the
determinant with respect to their first
equals what how can I figure out if I
change so what's this asking me to do
it's asking me to change X 1 1 by Delta
X and see what's the change in the
determinant right that's what determines
that's what derivatives are change X 1 1
a little bit how much did how much did
the determinant change and what see how
do i what what has the determinant of
the whole matrix got to do with X 1 1
you remember that there's a formula for
determinants so I need that fact the
determinant of X is X 1 1 times
something and it's that it's that
something that I really want to know
plus X 1/2 times others something plus
plus say along the first row times
another something what are these factors
that multiply the XS to give the
determinant what that gives is a linear
combination of the first row times
certain factors gives the determinant
and how do I know that there will be
such factors because the fundamental
property of the determinant is that it's
linear in Row 1 if I don't mess with
other rows it's a linear function of Rho
of Rho 1 so it is how
the form X 1 1 times something and what
is that something the determinant of the
of this so what is X 1 1 multiply when
you compute determinants X 1 1 will not
multiply any other guys in its row
because you never you never are
multiplying 2 X's in the same same row
or the same column what X 1 1 is
multiplying are all these guys in fact
it turns out to be it's the determinant
so this is so and what is this called
that that one smaller determinant that I
get by throwing away the first row and
first column it's called
when one minor is good yes minor is good
I was saying there are two words that
can be used minor and cofactor yeah and
what is it I mean how do i compute it
wasn't what is the number this is a
number and it's it's that it's just a
number but what maybe I think of the
minor as this determinant maybe I think
of the minor as this smaller matrix and
the cofactor which is the determinant of
the minor and there's a plus or minus
everything about determinants there's a
there's a there's a plus or minus choice
to be made and we won't we're not going
to worry about that
but so anyway so so it's the cofactor I
mean solar call it c11 and and so that's
the formula for the determinant
that's the cofactor expansion of a
determinant
okay and that will connect back to this
amazing fact that the gradient is the
entries of X inverse because the inverse
is the ratio of cofactor to determine so
X inverse 1 1 is that cofactor over the
determinant so that's where this anyway
I'm just mentioning that as a as a very
interesting example of a convex function
ok I'll leave that that's just for like
education ok now I'm ready to go to work
on on gradient descent so so actually
the rest of this class and Friday's
class about gradient descent are very
fundamental parts of this of the of 1806
5 and that will be one of our examples
and then the general case here ok ok so
I'm using this
I'm not going to it would be interesting
to minimize that thing but we're not
going there let's hide it so so we don't
see it again and I'll work with that
example ok so here's here's gradient
descent
is XK plus 1 is XK minus SK the step
size times the gradient of s at X okay
so the only thing left that requires us
to input some decision-making is the
step size the learning rate we can take
it as constant if we take too big a
learning rate the thing will oscillate
all over the place and where it's a
disaster if we take too small a learning
rate too small steps what's the matter
with that takes too long takes too long
so we the problem is to get it just
right and one way that you could say get
it right would be to think of optimize
choose the optimal SK of course that
takes longer than just deciding an SK in
advance which is what people do so I
think what people do is on really big
problems is take an SK estimate a
suitable SK and then go with it for a
while and then look back to see was it
if it was too big they'll see
oscillations in the you know it'll be
bouncing all over the place or of course
an exact line search so you see that
this expression often an exact line
search choose SK to make my function f
at XK plus 1 a minimum on the line on
the on their search line this in the
search a lot minimum in the
in the search direct the search
Direction is given by the gradient
that's the direction we're moving this
is the distance we're moving or a
measure of the distance we're moving and
an exact search would be to go along
there if I have a convex function then
as I move along this line as I increase
SK I'll see the function start down
because the gradient negative gradient
means down but at some point it'll turn
up again and that an exact line search
would find that point and stop there
okay that doesn't mean we would you know
we will see in this example where we
will do exactly searches that for a
small value of B it's extremely slow
that the condition number controls the
speed that's really what my message will
be just in these last minute and next
time the sort of key lecture on on
gradient descent ok so an exact line
search would be that so what a
backtracking line search backtracking
would be take a fixed s like 1 and then
be prepared to come backwards take it
take cut back by half see what you get
at that point cut back by half of that
to a quarter of the original step see
what that is
and when you if your so the the full
step might have taken you back to the
upward sweep halfway halfway forward
might still be on the upward sweep might
might be too much but so backtracking
cuts the
step size in pieces and and checks until
it so so so s not half of s not quarter
of s not or obviously a different
parameter a s not a squared s not and so
on until you're satisfied with with that
step okay and there of course many many
refinements we're talking about the big
algorithm here that everybody finds has
depending on their function has
different experiences with okay okay so
here's my here's my fundamental question
what if I do to think of an exact line
search how much does that reduce the
function how much does that reduce the
function so that's really what the
bounds that I want or how much does that
reduce the function and it will will
will see that the reduction involves
their condition number M over N so why
don't I turn to the example first and
then where the where we know exact
answers that gives us a basis for
comparison and we're then we're then our
mass goal is prove get s did bounds on
the size of F that that match what we
see exactly in that example where we
know everything we know that we know the
gradient we know the Hessian it's that
matrix we know the condition number so
what happens if I start at a point x0 y0
that's on my surface sorry what do I
want to do here that yeah I take a point
x0 y0 and okay so here here's the here's
the new XY k plus 1 is X Y K minus the S
times of which I can compute times the
gradient of F so I'm going to put in
gradient of F what is the gradient here
the gradient the derivative with respect
to X so I have a 2x okay and to be Y
okay right that's my and this is the
step size okay and for this small
problem where we're going to get such a
revealing answer I'm gonna choose exact
line search I'm going to choose the best
XK okay and what's the answer so let me
I just want to tell you what the
iterations are for that particular
function starting at x0 y0 start start
x0 y0 and I haven't done this
calculation myself it's taken from the
book by Stephen Boyd and Vandenberg
called convex optimization of course
they didn't weren't the first to do this
either but that's a I'm happy to mention
that book convex optimization and
Stephen Boyd will be on campus this
spring actually in in April for three
lectures
this is April maybe yeah okay
so it's this month in two or three weeks
and I'll tell you about that so okay so
here are the here are the X Ches and the
y case and the F and the function values
okay
so XK so where am I going to start yep
so I'm starting from the point X 0 y 0
equal B what it turns out that'll make
our formulas very convenient x0 y0
equals a b1 good so ok so XK is B times
the key ratio B minus 1 over B plus 1 to
the K power and YK happens to be one
might it's just it has this same ratio
and my function f has the same ratio -
this is FK has that same ratio 1 minus B
over 1 plus B to the K times f0 that's
my that's the beautiful formula that
we're we're gonna take as the best
example possible let's just see it K
equals 0 I have XK april-b YK 4 1
be serving a b-1 and that tells me the
rate of decrease of the function it's
the same ratio so what am i learning
from this example
what's jumping out is that this ratio 1
minus B over 1 plus B is is crucial
that's that that's the if B is large if
B is near 1 that ratio is small if B is
near 1 that's near 0 over 2 and I
converge quickly no problem at all
but if B is near 0 if it's if my
condition number is bad so the bad case
the hard case is small B plus 1 B is
small that ratio is very near 1 so I get
it's below 1 the ratio is below 1 so I'm
getting convergence I do get convergence
I do go downhill but what happens is I
don't go downhill very far until I'm
back headed back uphill again so the the
the picture to draw for this let me
change that picture to a picture in the
XY plane of the level sets yeah so the
picture really to see is in the XY plane
the level sets F equal constant that's
what a level said is it's a set of
points x and y where f has the same
value and what do those look like let's
see I think what do you think what are
the level sets look like for for this
particular function if I look at the the
curve x squared plus B Y squared evil
constant that's what a level set is this
is x squared plus B y squared equal or
constant what kind of a curve is that
that's an ellipse and what's up with
that ellipse what's the shape of it so
it's because there's no XY term that
ellipse is like well lined up with the
axes the the major axes of the ellipse
are on in the x and y directions because
there is no cross term here and we could
always have diagonalized our matrix if
it didn't if it wasn't diagonal and that
wouldn't have changed anything so this
is it's just rotating this base and
we've done that okay so what's the what
are the level sets look like they're
ellipses and suppose B is a small number
then what's with the ellipses if B is
small I have to go pretty I have to take
a pretty large Y to match a change in X
or I think maybe they're ellipses of
that sort are they they're lined up for
the axes and I hope I'm drawing the
right drawing on the right direction
they're long and thin is that right
because I would have to take a pretty
big Y to make up for a small B okay so
what happens when I'm descending this
this is a narrow Valley then think of it
as a valley which comes down steeply in
the Y direction but in the X direction
I'm crossing the valleys law so so what
happens if I if I take a point there oh
yeah I remember what to do
so let's that let's start at that point
on that ellipse okay now and those were
the level sets f equal constant so what
direction what's the first search
direction what direction do I move from
x0 y0
do I move along the ellipse absolutely
not because along the ellipse if it's
constant the gradient direction is
perpendicular to your lips so I move
perpendicular to the ellipse and when do
I stop pretty soon because very soon I'm
going back up again so I I start some
well I don't know whether you yeah I
haven't practiced with this curve but I
know one time's up thank God but what so
once again what do I know is going to
happen and by Friday we'll make it
happen so what's the what's what's
what's what do we see for the curve that
the the track of the it's say it's a
zigzag yeah so it's if we would like to
get here but we're not aimed here at all
so we zigzag zigzag and very slowly
approach that point and how slowly with
that with that that multiplier 1 minus B
over 1 plus B so that's the that's what
I'm learning from this example that
that's a key number and then you could
ask well what about general examples
this was one specially chosen example
with the exact solution well we'll see
at the beginning of next time that for a
convex function this is typical it's
this 1 minus B is the key is the
critical quantity or 1 over B or the how
small is B compared to 1 so that's that
will be the critical quantity and we see
it in this ratio 1 minus B over 1 plus B
so if B is 100th this is 0.99 over 1.01
it's virtually 1 ok so next time is a
sort of a key lecture to see what I've
just said
that this is that this controls the
convergence of steepest descent and then
to see an idea that speeds it up that
that idea is called momentum or heavy
ball so the physical idea is if you're
if you wanted to get if you had a heavy
ball right there and wanted to get it
down the valley toward the bottom you
wouldn't go perpendicular to the level
sets not at all you let the momentum of
the ball take over and let it roll down
so the the idea of momentum is to model
the possibility of letting that heavy
ball roll instead of directing it by
steepest descent at every point so
there's an extra term in steepest
descent the momentum turn that
accelerates it okay so Friday is the day
good see you then